Okay. I think I am looking at the camera. It has a little light on it,
so I can just watch that light.
Most of you around the world.
I'm in isolation here in my study in Nottingham,
before I went into isolation, Brady,
and I recorded some questions and answers.
And this little video is the last part of the recording we
made,
but we've noticed that things up in my study so we can record new
videos and they're all going to be coming up quite soon. But for now,
let's watch the last of the questions and answers that we recorded before
all of this started.
What is the stupidest thing you did in chemistry in your life?
I think the stupidest thing I did was when I was a school boy
and I tried to distill formic acid out of oven cleaner in
my parents' basement. I didn't look up the boiling point of formic acid,
but it's only one point something degrees above the boiling point of
water. So separating them by distillation is pretty difficult,
but more stupidly.
I did not put in any boiling beads into the
oven cleaner.
So I heated it up on an oil bath in my parents' basement.
And then suddenly I saw the temperature got very high to something like
150 degrees without it boiling.
And I dropped in some beads and it all
vaporized and clouds of acid vapor filled the
basement and we all had to retreat. Did you get in trouble?
I don't think my parents noticed it.
Okay. Have you seen breaking bad yet? No.
Do you get asked about our lives?
I occasionally get asked about it,
but I don't subscribe to any sort of streaming service,
plain biscuits or chocolate chip. I don't eat biscuits all that much.
And, but I suppose I prefer chocolate chip to plain biscuits.
If I have to.
What is the worst injury you have ever sustained in the pursuit of chemistry?
Touch wood?
I have never injured myself seriously though.
When I was a school boy,
we didn't wear gloves when we did chemistry.
And so my fingers were permanently stained yellow from
nitric acid and which makes your skin yellow and it eventually
peels off. And also when I was learning to glass blow,
I wasn't very successful because even then my hands shook rather. Um,
I burnt myself several times.
I can remember traveling on the London underground,
the underground trains, um,
and putting my finger against the metal to try and
make it hurt less. As I was going home from school.
What experiment do you wish all high school students would be required to
perform?
I've never thought about that.
I think the answer is that it doesn't really matter which experiments they
perform, but it's good if they perform lots of experiments,
some students around the frightened when they get to the lamp.
And so the more experiments you can do,
the more confidence you will get.
I think the really important thing to say is that modern
society relies on the use of chemicals.
And if we don't train young people to use chemicals
safely, then when they are my age,
there will be nobody in the world who can handle chemicals and the whole thing
will collapse.
So it's really important that people respect chemicals because they're often
dangerous, but at the same time,
have the confidence to handle them safely.
Are there any games you enjoy playing?
I used to play a little tennis, but I wasn't very good.
When I was a child,
I used to play Mahjong and I have a notice here in
my office saying, don't play Marshawn with strangers.
You're sure to be cheated. I play some games with my grandchildren,
but they like to change the rules. So they, when do you play chess?
I was very bad at chess. My father was very good.
I still have a chess set that he had as a child in Russia,
but it is missing one white Bishop
because he was playing it in the outside latrine and the
white Bishop fell down into the cesspit, but low,
he was playing chess in the toilet. Well working out chess problems.
Okay.
Have you ever played a video game or a computer game?
Um, I haven't, um,
played any video games my children used to in the early days so-called
BBC computer and I did help devise
some computer games for chemists,
for high school children.
And we prayed this help and our colleagues in computer file.
We've actually got these on the internet so you can play them to yourself if
you'd to. How.
Popular were you in your school days?
I think probably not very popular.
And my brother who's younger than me went to the same school as me,
after I had left. And this friend said they were frightened of me.
Why would they be frightened of you? I have no idea.
Cause you're a chemist. What's your favorite color? I don't know.
Probably green after all. I am a green chemist. And what's your favorite number?
I don't know, but um, most people say seven as far as I remember,
but I suppose at the moment it's probably 150 because it's 150 years
of the periodic table when that's 151 and
150 years of supercritical fluids, which was my big area of research.
Do you have any regrets? Everyone has regrets
except Edith PF. Who, if you remember her, the song
[inaudible], I don't
regret anything, but on the other hand, sometimes things that one regrets,
maybe
better that they didn't happen because the consequences of them might not have been as good
as one that
mentions. But I think I'm very pleased about many things, particularly meeting Brady, of course.
Did you ever meet Albert Einstein or Nikola Tesla?
The answer is no. And I think Einstein died when I was quite small.
I think he died in 55 when I would have been sufficiently young.
I wouldn't even know who he was.
Have you ever been starstruck?
I'm not sure. I mean, they
quite often when you meet somebody who's special
for one reason or another, it's quite difficult to see,
think what you would say to them.
I've sometimes wondered what would they say? If I met Mendeleev,
who I think was actually quite an eccentric and antisocial person,
I think as you get older, you tend to get less style struck.
And I'm quite embarrassed when people get star struck meeting
me,
how can they be star struck about somebody is ordinary is me.
Who's the most famous person you've met.
Depends how you define fame. Most recently,
I suppose the president of China Xi, Jinping,
whom I shook hands with,
but we appear to have no language in common and I've
met lots of Nobel prize winners,
and sometimes they're really quite conceited,
but very often they're delightfully modest and it's quite a privilege
to talk to them. Have you met the queen?
I've met the queen and Prince Charles who
asked me how green chemistry was going. You can see him on one of our videos.
Have you ever worked with Fleurieu and tympanic acid?
The short answer is no. In fact, I've never worked with fluorine.
I did once work in some dis lab where they had an argon
fluoride, laser contains Algon and fluorine inside
and it developed a leak and some of the fluorine
came out in the cooling water, into the lab,
in the form of HF hydrogen fluoride. And the smell was dreadful.
Do you know any periodic jokes?
No, not apart from cliched ones.
One of my colleagues like saying he has no chemical jokes,
they all are gone, but, um,
I don't really like such nonsense.
Do you collect anything like stamps or rocks?
I sometimes pick up nice stones on the beach or laying
around and I often give them to children who I know several children who
like collecting stones and I collect books.
You take lots of photos of flowers, don't you? Yes.
My wife is very interested in flowers, so I take pictures for her.
And I suppose in the last few years when I've got an iPhone and I like taking
pictures of all sorts of strange things, but, um,
what's the last thing you took a picture of?
The last thing I took a picture of is, um,
last thing I photographed was this,
which is a sale for liquid Xenon.
Haven't used it for probably 30 years.
And it's also, if you're interested in such things,
it's got these red windows,
which are made from a material called KRS five,
which is a mixture of titanium, iodide,
and bromate so it's quite dangerous to touch the windows.
Titanium is highly poisonous,
but I took a picture of this because I'm giving a lecture in 10 days time and I
needed to filter this.
What do you think will be the next big breakthrough in chemistry that will
change how we live our daily lives?
I think the biggest change probably is greatly improved
battery life at the moment,
the batteries that we have are good,
but they don't hold nearly enough charge.
Many people can't get through the day without their smart phone running down.
And the really important thing is that if you could make batteries
hold perhaps twice or three times the charge per unit
weight of what is possible today,
then you could start making electric aircraft.
At least for short range flights,
the electric cars would become much more viable than they are.
Now.
You may have heard the UK has declared few days ago that
no cars are going to be sold with petrol or diesel or
hybrid engines in 2035,
which is only 15 years from now.
And my car is more than 10 years old now.
So we've really got to make major developments in battery
technology.
How often do experiments work versus not work?
We used to have a sign on our lab door,
which was a quotation from the Nobel prize winner. Fred Sanger,
Fred Sanger is the only person who's ever won.
Two Nobel prizes in chemistry.
There's some people that have won two Nobel prizes,
but in different subjects and the quotation,
which used to be glued to our lab door said most experiments that work.
In fact,
if every experiment you do does work,
perhaps it means you're not trying things that are adventurous enough,
but what's really important about experiments.
You shouldn't just do them to see what happens,
but you sort of have some sort of hypothesis or idea of what's going to
happen. And then that may not happen.
But Naples you to change your theory.
Is salt. Dissolving in water, a chemical reaction or a physical reaction.
It's a physical process because if you evaporate the water,
you can get the salt back on the other hand,
if you drop a piece of sodium into water,
you get chemical reaction and you get to the solution of sodium
hydroxide. And when you evaporate,
it you'll get a white solid rather than the metal.
And you have to work quite hard to get the sodium back from it.
How does the professor view the increasingly close relationship between science
and business?
Well,
of course it depends what the relationship is that has always been
a strong interaction between chemistry and industry.
And most of the chemists that we educate go into
industry in some form or another industry,
the chemistry using industry are our biggest customers for our product
chemistry graduates. But I think that particularly now,
when society is faced with so many problems in terms
of sustainability of chemistry,
supplying the chemical needs of future generations,
it's really important for chemists to work with industry,
to make sure that we can continue supplying the chemicals that people
and they have had in my career.
Some really very good collaborations with industry and those
collaborations are continuing. And I really enjoy working with industry,
but professor can sort of chasing the mighty dollar impede
blue sky research,
those sort of crazy ideas that aren't necessarily financially viable,
but could open whole new avenues.
You don't have to do all your research with industry blue skies research in
general can be playing sometimes be quite inexpensive.
So even if you have an industrialist sponsored project,
you can still try extra ideas and so on.
And I have had several really good ideas that have been
inspired by spinoffs, from what I've done from industry.
Do you prefer coffee or tea, tea, green tea.
I don't like black tea very much.
And I used to be really addicted to coffee.
And then I went to China in 1998 when there was almost no coffee
there and you had to drink green tea.
And after a week I came back addicted, why do you prefer green tea?
Green tea is really good because you can put the leaves in your cup
and then you can add hot water to it all day. The same leaves,
the same leaves and it's still viable.
And if I drank as much coffee as I drink green
tea, I will be seeking 10 times more.
I really enjoy answering your questions. So keep sending them.
But for the moment we're recording new footage
and you'll be seeing those videos soon.
So keep watching at different speeds and from different.
[Inaudible]
professor Martin,
Poliakoff four seven shifts to the chemical sciences.
[inaudible].